it has been confirmed that the President
of the United States is being
investigated by the FBI for connections
to Russia and the Trump White House is
now scrambling at a hearing yesterday
the FBI director James Comey
was questioned by the House Intelligence
Committee and in his opening statement
confirmed that yes the FBI is conducting
an investigation into possible ties
between Russia and the Trump campaign
and James Comey sort of prefaced his
announcement by saying its bureau
practice not to confirm the existence of
ongoing investigations particularly when
they involve classified information but
that being an unusual circumstance he
had a statement to make and let's take a
listen to a little bit of that as you
know our practice is not to confirm the
existence of ongoing investigations
especially those investigations that
involve classified matters now it's
already funny right because what about
that entire Hillary Clinton thing that
might have swayed the election to trump
that was completed at the time I guess
but still had an impact but then there
was the letter not saying it was getting
reopened but it might be anyway
you remember that entire debacle so it's
already hilarious but regardless let's
continue
but in unusual circumstances where it is
in the public interest it may be
appropriate to do so as justice
department policies recognize this is
one of those circumstances I have been
authorized by the Department of Justice
to confirm that the FBI as part of our
counterintelligence mission is
investigating the Russian government's
efforts to interfere in the 2016
presidential election and that includes
investigating the nature of any links
between individuals associated with the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government and whether there was any
coordination between the campaign and
Russia's efforts as with any
counterintelligence investigation this
will also include an assessment of
whether any crimes were committed
because it is an open
ongoing investigation and is classified
I cannot say more about what we are
doing and whose conduct we are examining
little right late right Jimmy I mean
maybe if we knew some of this stuff at
the same time you did the entire Hillary
Clinton letter and press conference and
second letter is it now time to be
alarmed finally the President of the
United States is being investigated by
the FBI for potentially colluding with a
foreign power to take the White House
make America great again
but her emails were two months into a
new presidency Pat and one of the
scandals is that the president might
have worked with a foreign country in
order to get into the White House and
the thing is we've kind of known this
for a long time that the FBI had been
looking into Trump's Russia ties and had
been actually since July this past
summer but it's just nice to hear the
FBI director say it himself and it also
seems like Democrats went two for two on
this one because they provided no
evidence whatsoever that Obama wiretap
Trump Tower during the campaign yeah
that also no evidence for that we heard
from both NSA director Mike Rogers and
FBI director James Comey and what's not
being talked about enough is that the
FBI was investigating the Hillary email
situation and the Trump Russia
connection at the same time but only the
Hillary email investigation was publicly
mentioned by James Comey at the time
also if you listen to the to the hearing
which we did listen to quite a bit of it
here in the studio the Republicans on
the panel only wanted to talk about what
crimes reporters may have committed by
exposing that the president may have
been compromised by another country
you're missing the story Republicans we
have a president who might have been
compromised by foreign power and you
want to talk about well what would be
the penalty if a journalist leaked this
or that and adding by the way as Pat
mentioned no information supporting
Donald Trump's tweets alleging that he
was wire tapped by President Obama
mostly non answers of course from James
Comey beyond this statement finally the
day has come were we can be done with
the wiretap Fiasco and get back to the
real news
which is Russia until Trump makes yet
another defamation or distraction on
Twitter meant to distract from the
mounting scandals and just hours before
the start of this hearing Donald Trump
posted a series of tweets claiming that
Democrats quote made up all of the
Russian contact allegations to try to
discredit the Republican Party
everything Trump has alleged about this
Russian situation has slowly been shown
to be false Trump has not been truthful
about anything regarding this entire
Russia situation and Republicans on the
hill following the lead aggressively
questioning oh how did the classified
information get out there and ignoring
the implications of the president being
compromised by a foreign power trumpets
will be angry that Comey admitted this
investigation was happening but you have
to realize that it's Trump's tweets that
force the FBI to be in what they're
describing is this incredibly unusual
situation and revealing that there is
indeed an ongoing investigation do not
let the Republican Party normalize what
is going on because there is nothing
normal here this is scandal of the
highest order the new president in
office for not even two months and we
have a confirmed publicly confirmed FBI
investigation into the connections
between the president and a foreign
power
not a particularly friendly foreign
power and how that President might have
colluded with that country to get into
the White House